now guys you might have noticed that it
is absolutely frigid in here that's
because today in the Forge we are paying
tribute to some cold weather Warriors
who've been fighting the Ice for
centuries this is a competition we are
calling Arctic Forge in this first round
of competition we're going to ask you to
recreate a blade that has been used by
Alaskan natives for
centuries now that blade
is the
ULU when you're building your ULU I want
you to meet the these parameters you
need to have a crescent shaped Cutting
Edge that measures between 7 and 8 in
you also must have a fully enclosed Full
Tang handle now you guys are probably
thinking what am I going to make my ULU
out of well that answer lies at your
workstations on top of your table is you
have a tarp go ahead and remove that for
me what you guys have there is a great
piece of high-carbon Steel and a form of
a ball bearing but unfortunately it's
frozen in a block of ice we've got a
solution for you next to that block of
ice there is a cylinder of mild steel we
want you guys to take that mild Steel
make a tool and break the ball bearing
free good luck your time starts
now ice cold boys I got my mild still in
the Forge I decide to make a little
hammer out of it simple as that
basically just make a mace make a short
mace leave one end of it draw a little
handle onto It Whack It Whack It Whack
It it's a little
Hammer easy
psycho there you go good Lord once I see
that ball slides around I grab it and I
run back to the
forge my plan with the mild steel is to
forge out a pick I just need it to be
long enough to hold on to and to have a
sharp point so I can really really
attack that ice Andrew went straight for
big blue I had to smart move I get the
ball bearing out it's really cold I'm a
little worried about that but I don't
have time to let it warm up or anything
I just have to get it into the forge
taking that ball of Steel and just
throwing it into the forge is probably
not the best idea what could happen I
could shock it fracture it to the point
where you can't even fix
it my plan is to make a small hammer out
of the mild steel and go right at it I
broke out my ball bearing relatively
fast I'm feeling really good right now
[Music]
I'm looking at my steel I'm getting the
basic shape I need now I just got to
figure out how am I going to attack
getting a hole in this thing for a hand
to sit comfortably in I decide I'm going
to have to cut it on the angle grinder
I'd still prefer to use the hot wrench
and just blow a hole out seems like it'd
be the fastest I've been wasting so much
time just trying to get this hole out I
know the time's caught down I've been
trying to avoid cutting through the
bridge of this handle but it comes to
the point where I need to cut through
this handle it will completely just ruin
the Integrity of the blade in my
opinion I finally get the piece I need
off finally de's back of the welder he's
putting that chunk of handle material
that he cut off he's welding that back
on now the one thing about putting holes
into this piece is that it's got to have
enough space from the knuckles not tiny
a lot of space it looks good to me I
noticed that my handle Tang got too thin
for what I wanted
but I don't have time to fix that right
now if you notice he's got a lot of
Blade and a long spindly little handle
now that's going to roll in your hand if
he doesn't build that up with a lot of
handle material I'm feeling my blade and
I notice right where the handle connects
to the blade that there is some sharp
corners and you don't want sharp Corners
because that could cause a stretch
fracture so I got to fill it with some
weld that's definitely a smart
move
I'm really liking the overall shape of
this blade and now it's time to move on
to punching the hole through it for the
user's hand looking at Andrew's blade I
think it shape is really nice it's just
very very tall and having that pole
being that size you go and hit something
it could flop one way or the other
depending on handle construction and
really mess your hand up the problem
with having Corners the way I cut them
is that when you quench the blade those
are stress risers and it could create a
crack that just completely ruins the
edge I make the decision to go ahead and
weld up the corners because I know that
if the blade cracks welding that will
just not work at all all right guys
we're coming down to the wire you have
30 minutes left on the
clock Devon's actually turned out all
right yeah as I'm getting ready quench I
want to make sure I'm only focusing on
the edge that gets hot and not the rest
of the material if any the rest of
material gets hot I don't know what way
can warp and I am not prepared for that
or have the time to fix that I need this
thing to go perfect
woo and only quenching the edgeart nice
good for him
smart lord behold no warps straight as
an arrow now I just need to make sure
this sits comfortably and looks better
than it does right
now I'm getting ready to Quench and I
realize that I really have forged the
blade pretty thin and that could create
warping Andrews in the quench after the
quench I clamped the thing into the vise
when you do that it helps to straighten
everything out if I pull it out of the
vice the blade is straight I'm pretty
happy about how that came
out Edge qu my blade is straight and
it's hard and now off to the grinder I
need to clean up my blade I look
down there's a crack no no no no no no
no o I don't have time to fix this and
the forge so I run over to the welder
and I put a bead of weld along the crack
you know it really makes you wonder how
the ball bearing steel encased in ice
and then thrown into fire has affected
that steel you gave them time to start
to crack the ice open but nobody had the
patience to warm it up 3 2 1 gentlemen
turn off your machines put down your
tools this round is
over
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test and to keep with our
Arctic theme we're going with the Moose
antler punch and
chop remember this is not about what
your ULU does to the antler but what
that antler can do to your ULU clay
you're up first you ready I guess so
well I'm going to do it anyway Dave's
punched me before it's not that
[Laughter]
bad
holy sh Leep I take it
back all right clay let's talk about
your ULU now right off it's got a good
Cutting Edge and it didn't lose any of
that edge so that's good as far as the
handle goes it's a rough construction
without a glove on this is really not a
comfortable handle there are you know
parts that are kind of scking up but uh
didn't hurt my hand stayed where I
wanted it to be so good job thank you
all right Andrew you're up are you ready
knock it
[Music]
out so Andrew there's some obvious
issues with this when you were drilling
to mount the handle there was some
overworking and not good thermocycling
going on to reduce that grain structure
and give it the strength that it needs
once I hit just face on it just cut
loose you good yeah
yeah well Andrew that is an absolutely
tough break unfortunately you had a
catastrophic failure in your blade which
means we cannot test your ULU
further clay congratulations that means
you're moving forward into round three's
competition Devin not quite out of the
woods yet you got to make it through a
solid punch ready yeah let's get weird
all right let's do it
Dave get weird careful what you asked
for so Devon Your Design is pretty much
spoton for an ULU as far as holding up
in this test you really didn't take in
any damage at all I feel like I could
work with this either skinning or
chopping and the blade held up
beautifully nicely done thank
you well gentlemen you guys all did a
great job but Andrew unfortunately we
can't continue testing and your time
here in the Forge has ended man I'm
going to have to ask you to please step
out let the young dogs play it wasn't a
big shock for me when the blade failed
there were a lot of things wrong with
that blade and it would have taken a
miracle for me able to get through to
the finale my wife's been bugging me to
make her in ULU so when I get home one
of the first things that I'll do is make
a decent ULU that'll be useful in the
kitchen and it's not going to be used to
punch handlers or do crazy stuff like
[Music]
that